MASSIVE VOTE RECOUNT UNDERWAY IN
FLORIDA.
NEW LAWSUITS ARE FLYING AND THE
RHETORIC ARE RAMPING UP IN THE
SENATE RACE BETWEEN RICK SCOTT
AND BILL NELSON.
SCOTT'S ELECTION NIGHT LEAD
NARROWING TO JUST UNDER 13,000
AS HE ACCUSES NELSON AND
DEMOCRATS OF TRYING TO STEAL THE
ELECTION.
>> BILL NELSON IS CLEARLY A SORE
LOSER.
HE CAN'T STAND THE FACT THAT
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE ELECTED FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN DECADES AND HE
WON'T -- HE IS HERE TO STEAL THE
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DONE.
HIS LAWYER SAID I'M HERE TO WIN
THE ELECTION.
NOT HERE TO GET A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION, MAKE SURE VOTES ARE
COUNTED.
NO, HE WANTS TO WIN.
THAT'S HIS ONLY PURPOSE.
WE STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY WENT IN THESE COUNTIES.
THEY CAME UP WITH 93,000 VOTES
AFTER ELECTION NIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW THEY CAME UP
WITH IT.
WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE WHAT
HAPPENED.
I HAVE ASKED THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GO IN AND DO AN INVESTIGATION
AND FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
WE KNOW THAT THE JUDGES HAVE
SAID THEY CLEARLY VIOLATED THE
LAW.
>> Dana: NELSON IS CALLING ON
SCOTT TO RECUSE HIMSELF IN THE
RECOUNT PROCESS.
>> RICK SCOTT ISN'T INTERESTED
IN MAKING SURE EVERY LAWFUL VOTE
IS COUNTED.
THE SECOND IS HE'S USING HIS
POWER AS GOVERNOR TO TRY TO
UNDERMINE THE VOTING PROCESS.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEETING THAT FLORIDA'S
ELECTIONS ARE "MASSIVELY
AFFECTED AFTER REPORTS THAT
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS WERE MIXED
UP IN BROWARD COUNTY."
HERE WE GO, GREG, ONE BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS RECOUNT
AND THE ONE EVERYONE REMEMBERS
FROM 2000 IS THAT BUSH AND GORE
WERE SEPARATED BY A FEW HUNDRED
VOTES.
THIS IS AT LEAST 13,000 VOTES.
MOST PEOPLE THAT I TALKED TO
TODAY SAID THEY EXPECT ONCE THE
RECOUNTS ARE DONE THAT SCOTT
WILL BE THE WINNER.
>> Greg: I LOVE THE PHRASE
MASSIVELY INFECTED.
THEY ACT LIKE IT'S A FIRST TIME.
THIS IS AN OIL CHANGE AND A
TUNEUP FOR DEMOCRACY.
THEY ARE LIKE SOAP OR CHARACTERS
WITH AMNESIA.
OH, MY GOD.
WE HAD NO IDEA WE HAD TO DO
THIS.
IN THE SAME TWO COUNTIES.
IT'S TYPICAL BUREAUCRATIC
INCOMPETENCE THAT DRIVES ME
NUTS.
I KNOW THAT WE BLAME FLORIDA BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY THE COUNTIES.
BROWARD COUNTY.
IF FLORIDA WITH THE BRADY BUNCH,
BROWARD COUNTY'S COUSIN OLIVER.
COMES LATE, VERY IRRITATING,
RUINS THE WHOLE SHOW.
I'M REALLY ANNOYED BY PEOPLE WHO
SAY IF YOU DARE TO QUESTION THE
VOTING SYSTEM, IT'S AN ATTACK ON
DEMOCRACY.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO SAID THAT IF
YOU DOUBTED RUSSIA AFFECTED
2016, IT WAS LIKE TREASON.
>> Dana: LAWRENCE, THEY ARE
NOT SURE THEY CAN FINISH THE
RECOUNT IN TIME.
THE JUDGE SAYS YOU HAVE TO DO
IT.
IT'S MIXED UP IN THE COURTS.
>> Lawrence: THEY DIDN'T MEET
THE DEADLINE, WHICH WAS
SATURDAY.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE DEBATING
THE REASONING.
IT'S IRRELEVANT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BROWARD COUNTY,
THERE'S A LOT OF SHADY BUSINESS,
DESTROYING BALLOTS.
COUNTING ON LAWFUL VOTES, NOT
MEETING DEADLINES.
ALL OF THOSE, WHETHER IT'S
BECAUSE YOU ARE SUPPORTING A
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE, YOU'RE NOT
MEETING THE STANDARD.
THIS DIDN'T START WITH THE NEW
LEADERSHIP IN 2003 BUT HER BOSS
GOT FIRED FOR NEGLECT,
MISMANAGEMENT AND INCOMPETENCE.
THIS IS A HISTORY IN
BROWARD COUNTY.
THE QUESTION IS WHY DIDN'T
RICK SCOTT FIRE HER WHEN HE HAD
CONTROL OF THIS, BEFORE THIS
BECAME ABOUT HIS RACE?
THIS INCOMPETENCE HAS BEEN GOING
ON A LONG TIME.
I THINK THIS IS HOW YOU GOT A
DONALD TRUMP IN OFFICE.
IF HE WAS RUNNING THIS STATE,
SHE WOULDN'T HAVE FIRED HIM A
LONG TIME AGO.
>> Dana: DID HE HAVE POWER TO
FIRE HER?
>> Nicole: I THINK RICK SCOTT
DID SAY HE DIDN'T HAVE THE POWER
TO DO THAT.
>> Dana: JUAN, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> Juan: IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE
OF FRAUD?
THEY SAY NO, THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE.
YOU ASK REPUBLICANS WHAT
EVIDENCE DO YOU HAVE TO SAY WE
SHOULD STOP THE RECOUNT, THEY
SAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY BUT WE ARE
SUSPICIOUS.
WHAT YOU HEAR FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HOW COME THEY
NEVER FIND ANY REPUBLICAN VOTES.
THEY DO FIND REPUBLICAN VOTES
WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH
BROWARD COUNTY AND I THINK IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR THAT NELSON, IT'S A
STRONGHOLD FOR SENATOR NELSON.
IT'S ALSO TRUE, TO PICK UP ON
WHAT LAWRENCE WAS SAYING, I
THINK I HAVE NUMBERS HERE TO
INDICATE 4,600 RECOUNTS OR
REVIEWS BETWEEN 2000 AND 2016.
26 OF THOSE 4,000 THAT RESULTED
IN ANY CHANGE IN THE OUTCOME.
WE HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE
REPUBLICAN SAYING STOP IT, BOY,
DOES IT LOOK POLITICAL.
YOU KNOW WHO THEY ARE STOPPING?
AS WE CELEBRATE VETERANS DAY,
OVERWHELMINGLY THE MAIL-IN
BALLOTS COME FROM THE MILITARY.
>> Dana: THERE WAS A QUESTION,
THE BALLOTS THAT DIDN'T COUNTED
CORRECTLY IN THE DIFFERENT ONES.
NOT HANGING CHANCE, DR. SAPHIER,
BUT IT IS OF CONCERN.
THE INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTION IS
IN QUESTION.
AT THIS POINT, IT SEEMS LIKE NO
MATTER HOW IT TURNS OUT, HALF
THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO THINK IT
WAS RIGGED AGAINST THEM.
>> Nicole: RECOUNTS DON'T
CHANGE WHEN YOU HAVE A FIVE
DIGIT LEAD.
WE KNOW THAT.
I TAKE JUAN'S PRAGMATIC
APPROACH.
AS SOON AS THE RECOUNTS ARE
DONE, THE REPUBLICANS ARE STILL
GOING TO WIN.
THE THING THAT BOTHERS ME, IT
BECAME MORE POLITICAL THAN IT
NEEDED TO.
LEGALLY IT WAS A NARROW MARGIN
IN THE KNEE NEED TO DO THE
RECOUNT.
THAT'S FOLLOWING THE RULE OF
LAW.
WE ARE DOING THE RECOUNT AND NOW
IT'S GETTING POLITICIZED, YOUR
TWEETS ON BOTH SIDES YELLING AT
EACH OTHER AND IT DOES CAUSE
CONSTERNATION FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND FOLLOWING THE RULE OF
LAW, I DON'T REALLY LIKE SEEING
COUNTING BALLOTS PAST THE
DEADLINE, SAYING THAT
INVALIDATED BALLOTS ARE GOING TO
GET VALIDATED.
TAKE THOSE ON ELECTION NIGHT,
COUNT THOSE.
>> Juan: WHEN I HAVE TROUBLE
WITH IS THE IDEA THAT IN
GEORGIA, U OF BRIAN KEMP WHO IS
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR BUT ALSO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CHARGE
THE ELECTION.
IN FLORIDA, HERE YOU HAVE THE
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT NOW TRYING
TO INTERFERE WITH THE SYSTEM AND
WHAT YOU HEAR FROM --
>> Dana: HOW IS HE
INTERFERING?
>> Juan: HE IS SAYING THAT HE
WANTS IT DONE THIS WAY AND HE
WANTS TO STOP FUND --
>> Lawrence: IS NOT ILLEGAL.
IN 2016, THE JUDGE FOUND --
>> Juan: THIS IS 2018.
>> Lawrence: THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THERE'S A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR
IN THAT OFFICE.
THE JUDGE, SHE SHOULDN'T BE
THERE.
>> Juan: THE PATTERN THAT I
SEE IS THAT YOU HAVE REPUBLICAN
OFFICEHOLDERS WHO DECIDE THEY
CAN INTERFERE IN AN ELECTION
WHEN THEY DON'T LIKE SOMETHING
GOING ON.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE TO THINK --
>> Lawrence: NOT TO MEET THE
DEADLINE.
SUNSHINE LAW.
>> Juan: IF THE JUDGES SAW ANY
OF THAT, THEY WOULD SAY THERE'S
SOMETHING.
>> Greg: IF I HAD TO PICK WHO
TO TRUST IN A FIGHT OVER
BALLOTS, IT WOULD BE THE PARTY
THAT IS FOR VOTER I.D., NOT THE
ONE AGAINST IT.
THAT'S ONE WAY TO LOOK AT IT.
THERE'S ALWAYS ONE FOR A PROCESS
MORE RELIABLE.
>> Dana: EVEN IF YOU HAVE
VOTER I.D., YOU STILL HAVE THIS
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM WITH THIS
PAPER.
I KNOW THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
HACKING IF YOU DO SOMETHING
ELECTRONICALLY BUT IT SEEMS TO
ME --
>> Greg: IF WE CAN TRUST OUR
FINANCIAL --
>> Dana: EVERYTHING YOU CAN DO
ON HERE.
>> Juan: I WOULDN'T TRUST THE
PARTY THAT IS FOR VOTER
SUPPRESSION.